I need I know you like this a little  Entertainment Tonight post I don't even  I just uh I just found it right here  look at that Sharna Burgess is there  anything there doesn't she she is a babe  so hot oh my god  it's shocking are you confirming that  there's a little something there I mean  I have a crush on her for sure I don't  know if we're dating have you gone out  on a date maybe who knows he's so funny  I saw last night he did and he didn't he  was very sweet  yeah he's a good boy he's a lovely guy I  know I was a congratulations to him for  being nominated for an Emmy that's super  super awesome he's got great things  ahead of him I know you love when I do  stuff like that so I decided I love it  when you guys do that it's so much fun  you're welcome she's the most confident  woman that I know and I will love you  and here's the thing she's like a  down-to-earth chick who is I mean  everything the total pack Oh completely  I wish I wish we were dating  [Music]  you  [Music]